know we are at an inflection point i
believe in the world economy not just
the world economy in the world it occurs
every three or four generations
as one of them as the one of the top
military people said to me in a secure
meeting the other day
60 60 million people died between 1900
and 1946
and uh since then we established a
liberal world order and that hadn't
happened in a long while a lot of people
dying but nowhere near the chaos
and now is the time when things are
shifting we're gonna they're gonna be a
new world order out there and we've
gotta lead it we've gotta unite the rest
of the free world and do it
well you heard it right there from the
president of the united states himself
the new world order is being ushered in
i am but your humble video show host
dave rubin this is the reuben report
it's march 22nd 2022 that's a lot of
twos
and uh yeah the new world order is here
but it has not stopped us from live
streaming on rumble youtube and blaze tv
please subscribe to rumble.com
reuben report if you have not uh our
whole show today is going to be about
the new world order because joe biden
said the new world order is coming in
and the u.s better lead and then of
course immediately what happened after
that immediately because it's incredible
how the machine operates twitter put up
a topic they're trending topics and they
explain that joe biden didn't really
mean that and if you believe that a new
world order's coming you're a conspiracy
theorist even though the guy just said
it himself
we are going to lay out the case we've
got one of those narrative shows for you
today we are going to lay out the case
that it actually is coming and
everything that the democrats and the
administration and the powers that be
and the media etc etc have been doing
for the last two plus years at least and
probably far longer than that has been
designed to usher in this new world
order and i just want to say to our new
lizard overlords love you guys you guys
are doing great and thank you we're just
happy to be here uh before we get to any
of that though guys i want to remind you
that the don't burn this country book
tour
is up tickets are for sale they are
selling fast uh and we've just announced
a new guest that i had been teasing but
here we go in orlando florida we're
kicking this thing off on april 18th
we'll announce the guest on that one
soon april 19th and next night in west
palm beach we'll announce the guest on
that one soon as well clearwater florida
on april 20th we've got benny johnson
april 21st in raleigh north carolina
we've got andrew clavin april 22nd in
atlanta georgia we've got the willy
wonka of politics michael malus april
23rd chicago illinois we're going to
announce that one soon too the guest
april 24th my man glenn beck in dallas
texas april 25th megan mccain in
washington d.c april 26 we've got megyn
kelly in west niagara new york may 12th
brea california we've got dennis prager
uh sorry that was may 11th in brea may
12th in oxnard i fight excuse me i can
finally officially confirm we've got
larry elder it's official he's coming
and we're going to do our thing the
return of reuben and elder uh may 12th
in oxnard california may 15th san jose
will announce the guest on that one soon
may 16th phoenix
i think i can announce this one tomorrow
probably and then may 18th denver and
then we'll add some more dates yes we're
working on nashville i want to get into
the middle of the country a little bit
more this was just an initial jump in
you can buy tickets at daverubin.com
events the vip tickets are all going
super fast people want the handshake and
the what second hug so get in there get
your tickets now and before we get to
anything else and then i promise you we
got a big show for you today you're
going to be very happy with the program
i ask nothing of you other than to sit
back and enjoy it today and i promise
you you will i want to talk to you guys
about bonner private wine do you know
what's in the wine bottle sitting on
your kitchen counter you probably don't
and traditional media won't tell you
this they've got oak flavoring mega
purple dye and tons of sugar and that's
not counting all the chemicals left over
from vineyards that look more like oil
refineries than the great chateaus of
old but better wines do exist and they
don't cost an arm and a leg either take
it from america's top explorer recently
he came across a wine unlike anything
he's ever tasted problem is this
delicious red wine can only be found in
a single isolated corridor known as the
world's most remote wine valley heck he
nearly died twice trying to find these
vineyards the wine is that special want
to give them a try today over at bonner
private wines my audience can get these
rare wines at half the retail price no
need for a promo code plus you'll get 50
off shipping the wine is truly something
special but supplies are limited visit
bonnerprivetwines.com dave to claim your
wine that's bonner privatewise.com dave
and now back to me we are having some
friends over tonight we are smoking a
leg of lamb and i will be drinking a
nice malbec there you go all right
so i want to show you one more time
the video of president joe biden telling
us that the new world order is coming
you know we throw that up there
i believe in the world economy not just
the world economy in the world it occurs
every three or four generations
as one of them as the uh one of the top
military people said to me in a secure
meeting the other day
60 60 million people died between 1900
and 1946
and uh since then we established a
liberal world order and that hadn't
happened in a long while a lot of people
dying but nowhere near the chaos and now
is a time when things are shifting we're
going to they're going to be a new world
order out there and we've got to lead it
and we've got to unite the rest of the
free world in doing it
oh
i don't remember
joe biden saying anything about a new
world order when he was running for
president
do you guys remember anything about that
that sounds more like i don't know alex
jones kind of conspiracy stuff like
globalist new world order i don't
remember anything about that i remember
tolerance and diversity and unity
but now we've got a new world order and
a new world order that he says the
united states has to lead which that's
even more funny than the idea of a new
world order in and of itself as if these
people could lead anything but anyway
that is exactly what joe biden said
yesterday okay he also that was it sort
of was ominously like oh a lot of people
are about to die so we can usher this
thing in because that's what happens
when we get these new world orders but
let's put that aside for just a sec he
said that you heard it there
for yourself here's what twitter said
about it like a minute later
new world order it was trending in
politics unfounded claims about the new
world order conspiracy theory are
discussed after president joe biden used
the phrase as he spoke about the united
states response to russia's invasion of
ukraine during an address at business
roundtable ceo quarterly meeting so he
says new world order then people start
talking about new world order and then
of course twitter frames it as but crazy
people are the ones really talking about
the new world order now the thing is um
it's fairly obvious it is fairly obvious
that that is what these people have been
ushering in when you look at everything
that has transpired over the last couple
years when you look at the riots in the
streets when you look at the collapsing
economy when you look at the disaster of
afghanistan when you look at this war
that feels very fabricated or at least
unclear and murky as to what's really
going on
when you hear them
talk about globalism when you hear the
world economic forum people talk about
you won't own anything and you'll be
happy it's like yeah you guys have
actually been ushering this in this
entire time and it is not a conspiracy
theory so over the course of the next 20
minutes or so we're going to go back
we're going to rewind the clock because
i always say it's important to remember
what they said and what they were doing
so that you can figure out where we're
at at this very moment and i think we've
laid out a pretty solid case that this
has been their intentions it's exactly
what they're doing and they're going to
keep coming
but before i do that i want to talk to
you guys about roman healthcare you know
when the moment for intimacy arrives you
need to be ready roman ready whether
you've been in a relationship for years
or just getting started having the
confidence that comes from preparation
means you're free to enjoy the moment
when the moment comes even though you
are far from ordinary the truth is that
ed is really common in fact 52 of guys
aged 40 to 70 experience some form of
erectile dysfunction with roman you can
get a free online evaluation and ongoing
care for erectile dysfunction all from
the comfort and privacy of your home a
u.s licensed healthcare professional
will work with you to find the best
treatment plan if medication is
appropriate it'll ship to you for free
with two day shipping roman system is
completely confidential and totally
discreet no big logos or labels on the
packages getting started is simple just
go to getroman.com ruben and complete an
online visit the benefits of ed
treatment can help you reconnect with
your partner and rediscover the joy of
sex go to getroman.com ruben today and
if you're prescribed get 15 bucks off
your first month of ed treatment make
sure you're ready to have confidence and
control this spring roman ready and now
back to me okay little heavy on ads up
top i agree i'll control it going
forward uh but okay now we are going to
lay out the case joe biden said
there is a new world order on its way
and the u.s has to lead it twitter said
if you say that you're a conspiracy
theorist even though the old master just
said it
well let's go into what's happened over
the last couple years has something been
happening in the united states and
perhaps across the world has a series of
events happened that would lead us to
believe that they are trying to destroy
western society
let's start perhaps with policing and
what's gone on with policing and
politics are how do our politicians talk
about policing and what sort of chaos
maybe that's led to on the streets of
our cities here's some of my favorite
politicians
so we've been talking about defunding
the police there's some issues that we
ask police to do like mental health
issues or policing in schools and all
the rest that perhaps we can
shuffle some of that money around suck
it up defunding the police has to happen
we need to defund the police mayor eric
garcetti saying take some of the money
from policing about 150 million dollars
i applaud eric garcetti for doing what
he's done not only do we need to
disinvest
we need to foreign dismantle the
minneapolis police department so yes
defund your butts defund you we will be
moving funding from the nypd to youth
initiatives and social services they are
talking about reducing
the allocation of resources to that
department and i think every single
city in this country ought to be
thinking about the same thing yes i
support the defund movement i'm for
responsible reallocation of resources
and defund the police i think you do all
those other things you don't need all
the money that's going in the police
department so yeah i mean the spirit of
it i i do support that we propose to
redirect over seven million dollars from
the police bureau that our city through
our city administrative officer identify
250 million dollars
in cuts proceeded to leave tweeting no
more policing incarceration and
militarization it can't be reformed when
they're saying defund the police what
are they saying
they're saying we want fundamental basic
change when it comes to policing
uh and they're right
all right so the full video there goes
on for another five minutes now those
were all democrats i i asked my guys can
we find any videos of republicans
calling for defunding the police i don't
want to be totally partisan here if it's
not the case we couldn't find any
but i think you see what i'm doing here
so
here are people after the last two years
many of those people are no longer in
their jobs thankfully andrew cuomo would
be the the highlight of that um
but here are people who have called for
more debt they have called for more
destruction in our cities and we know
exactly what has happened that is
exactly what has happened to our cities
we now know that two years after all the
riots and everything else and it is kind
of funny you know where are the riots
these days whatever happened to blm did
they ever do anything good for the black
community whatever whatever that phrase
means in sense of community um did they
solve systemic racism why aren't they
out there rioting and destroying cities
anymore
could it have something to do with that
orange guy being gone could this have
all been a sham and really coordinated
through the democrats and their media
allies
dave what are you talking about um
but this is what they brought on us and
it's intentional right because they were
telling us hey this is what we are going
to do then it got so bad that some of
them have slightly backtracked but it's
not just the policing it's actually what
they're also doing to our borders and
our ability to deal with people who are
here illegally here is vice president
kamala harris talking about ice
a lot of the signs at the rally you just
held or people standing there saying
abolish ice yeah is that a position that
you agree with
listen i think there's no question that
we've got to critically re-examine ice
and its role and the way that it is
being administered and the work it is
doing and we need to probably think
about starting from scratch
boy that's a real shock to barack obama
because he loved dice and we deported an
awful lot of people
under uh barack obama guess he's a
racist
um
i think you see the point of what we're
doing there so okay let's get clear here
they don't like the police so that
caused a lot more violence on our
streets they don't like ice and by the
way kamala harris isn't the only one we
could have picked plenty of videos
anyone from the squad and bernie sanders
and anybody else trying to get rid of
ice ice's job is to make sure if they
find people that are here illegally so
you are inherently breaking the law if
you're here illegally they figure out
what to do with you whether they're
going to detain you or send you back to
your country of origin et cetera et
cetera now we can have some level of
discussion how much we should fund that
and what they what the processes are
related to what they do when they
capture somebody and what what our
border policies should be right like we
could have a really honest conversation
about that it's very hard to do because
there was again that orange guy and i
always forget his name who was saying
you know build a wall you have a border
and if you don't have a border you don't
have a country now it's kind of like
that's sort of what the democrats are
saying right now as they're letting all
of these people in so okay they want to
get rid of the police they want to get
rid of you know the people who are
protecting our borders but it's not just
the people who are protecting our
borders and making sure that legal
people here in the united states they
actually want to just ram through
the border altogether here's a video we
showed you this a couple months back
this is september 2021
del rio texas this is our mexican
texan border
beneath this border bridge in del rio
texas a group of migrants grows by the
hour the men women and children mostly
from haiti tonight they number nearly 15
thousand tripling in size since
wednesday all waiting in near 100 degree
heat washing clothes in the rio grande
and sleeping outside for a chance to
claim asylum we need the administration
secretary mayor is the vice president
and the president to call this what it
is this is a crisis
with staff unable to keep up with
processing state lawmakers are calling
on washington for help
did you catch the part about most of
them being haitian i have no problem
with haitians but when people think of
the mexican border they think it's just
mexicans coming over but we now know
that it's people literally from all over
the world
haiti included and all over the middle
east and everywhere else eastern europe
western europe they get to mexico and
then they just walk over
so let's go back through the case
they're getting rid of the police
they don't like the police and that led
to a lot of destruction they don't want
ice the people who are trying to make
sure that once people are in here we can
deal with them properly because you've
already broke the law of the united
states and if we don't know who's here
we have a big problem on our hand and
they're basically erasing the border and
if you want some actual statistics on
that here's data from the u.s customs
and border protection
this is southwest land border encounters
year over year so in 2020 so this is
basically illegal people that are trying
to get over the border in 2020 there
were 458
000
such instances in 2021
it basically tripled more than tripled
to
1.73 million
and then in october of 2021 to february
of 2022 roughly four months
838 000 interactions whatever that fully
means the full context of what that
means
between border agents and people getting
here illegally so
you see the case people think you got it
so they're telling us they want a new
world order but if you if you say you're
a conspiracy theorist but that's what
joe biden's saying they're taking out
the police they're taking out ice they
are uh taking out our borders so i
thought well look that seems an awful
lot dave this is getting very scary but
it must end there there can't be more
evidence that these people are trying to
destroy the united states of america in
honor of some sort of new world order
that seems bananas
well let's talk about inflation we've
got some info here
first off we have that insane six
trillion dollar rescue plan right
everybody knows about that which was you
know you just print money people you
just print money and you see what
happens that's how it works okay
so be it uh we have this image that
you're looking at here from the u.s
inflation calculator the annual
inflation rate for the united states
right now
is 7.9 percent for the 12 months ending
in february 2022 the highest since
january 1982 after rising 7.5
previously in 2021 according to u.s
labor department data published
march 10th now again without getting
into crazy politics here and crazy uh
economics
when inflation rises your money is worth
less and then goods cost more inflation
bad
but fear not people joe biden the guy
warning us of the new world order that's
not really coming he is also telling us
that his policies and what he's doing
has nothing to do with inflation even
though we didn't really have it under
orange man and it suddenly is going
bananas under senile man
i'm sick of this stuff
[Applause]
we have to talk about it because the
american people think the reason for
inflation is government spending more
money
simply not true
well if he's sick of it then obviously
it isn't true but of course it's true by
not true he means true when the
government makes up money and just
prints money endlessly based on nothing
based on no gold standard or anything
else right when it just literally goes
to the printing presses and says let's
just flood the system with more money
and or borrow money from other people
any of you who have ever borrowed money
from anybody when you borrow money from
people what happens when you go back to
the people you say you borrow 100 bucks
from a friend right we've all borrowed
money from somebody at some point right
i remember once a little bit after
college i borrowed i think 500 bucks
from a buddy and it's like okay you then
have to pay that person back and maybe
they charge you interest maybe they
don't uh but you can't keep going back
to them oh i borrowed 500 ah can i get a
little bit more you know you can do that
and this is what happens with the mafia
next thing you know you're in debt ten
thousand dollars and then they got to
break your legs and take you out to the
swamp in jersey okay and that's what
china is probably going to do to us at
some point because they are our bank in
essence at this point so we print money
we don't have we don't have we are a
debtor nation it's just how it is okay
and then we also what are we trying to
pass a 14 billion dollar billion 14
billion for ukraine it's like i'm pretty
sure some americans could use a little a
little bit of that but we did get our 16
cent savings remember in on july 4th the
white house actually put up an image
that you will save 16 cents on your july
4th feast god these freaks
this is bad this is bad but don't worry
joe biden says it has nothing to do with
him it has nothing to do with him
endlessly printing money it has nothing
to do with him destroying the economy
and shutting down businesses and
everything else there's nothing to do
with him now the irony of course is that
i'm fairly certain that if the economy
was chugging along super well right now
and if we were all rolling and doing the
monopoly man was you know handing out
cash every time you pass go uh i'm
pretty sure biden would be like yeah
it's me well he don't know where he is
but like somebody around there would be
saying this is all because of joe biden
and the democrats
these democrat policies have saved
everybody and there's more money and
everything's great but you just know
it's not true you know it's not true
from the price of oil and gas and
everything else and actually let's talk
about the price of oil and gas we've got
some data here from markets insider the
price of oil per barrel this morning
this very morning
and 25 cents the day of biden's
inauguration just a little bit over a
year ago 53 dollars and 24 cents so it
has just more than doubled just more
than doubled the price of gas so okay so
let's see what they're doing let's back
it up
taking out the police taking out ice
taking out the borders
inflation up gas prices up boy
if these people if the goal is to
destroy everything they're doing a hell
of a job about it right they're doing a
heck of a job and here's the key video
now that i want you to see here because
they're doing it intentionally and there
simply is no doubt about it here is a
compilation of democrats talking about
why
they're doing all of this
and uh you know how you are just gonna
have to suck it up you peon the future
of transportation is electric gas prices
have hit a new record high in america
and expect it to keep rising you need to
make sure that it becomes relatively
more attractive to have an electric
vehicle instead of a gas you want gas
prices to go up in oil prices you need
it to reflect the true cost of carbon
number one no more subsidies for fossil
fuel industry no more drilling on
federal lands no more drilling including
offshore no ability for the oil industry
to continue to drill period ends record
high gas prices the national average now
at four dollars and 29 cents a gallon a
60 cent hike in just one week the
president is really focused on making
sure that people are not heard of the
pump several around la that are more
than six bucks a gallon if you drive an
electric car this would not be affecting
you clearly there's no sound or fuel how
many barrels of oil does the us consume
per day i don't have that number in
front of me so how do i know it's
actually working what is the grand home
plan to increase oil production in
america
oh my god
that is hilarious perhaps if you let the
market work in this respect people will
feel pain they'll take a second look at
that ford f-450 gigantoid truck they'll
reconsider a tesla i'm willing to pay
four dollars a gallon hell i'll pay 15
a gallon because i drive a tesla i have
a chevy bolt that is my car i lease a
bolt
and i lease
solar panels so i drive on sunshine girl
these people are all better than you
guys
they have more than you and they want
you to know that now i want to admit
something here i just got a new tesla
last week i did
i work very hard i have a couple
successful businesses
i lease the tesla which actually is
probably not the best idea because
tesla's because of all of this will
retain their value over the years
i'm not against electric cars the tesla
is one of the coolest
uh innovations that we've had in america
worldwide actually in the last 20 years
it really is it's really like driving a
different thing than driving a regular
car like it's all
digital to drive to go forward you have
to slide your finger up to go backwards
you have to slide your down like it's
just super cool the automated driving
all of the stuff okay so i'm not sitting
here telling you that electric is bad
it's not and if we could figure out a
way to to convert to more renewable
energy
safely and securely and also not destroy
the economy at the exact same time and
if any of this would have any real
effect on the environment which is a
whole separate topic knowing that we can
only control what we do within our
borders but other countries going
through their own industrial revolutions
china india for example huge massive
countries doing whatever they want if
they're going to keep doing all of that
stuff and we're just going to harm our
economy in the name of green energy
we're going to be worse off the simple
truth is that fossil fuels
and gas and fracking and all of these
things and especially nuclear
these are the things that are still the
best way to raise more people up out of
poverty i actually watched an incredible
movie if you haven't seen it's like 10
years old i watched there will be blood
over the weekend on netflix and it's all
about the the oil rush in the late 1800s
it goes into probably the 1920s 1930s
really fantastic movie um who's the
actor and there will be blood guys a
freaking incredible actor um
anyway they are trying to destroy
everything give me that guy's name real
quick before we move on daniel day-lewis
the guy is he's really like you know
they say actors you know i don't like
what they say actors or geniuses it's
like tom hanks didn't really go to the
moon uh you know he pretended to that
doesn't make you a genius but this guy
daniel daley was like great actor anyway
they are trying to destroy the whole
damn thing they really are here is video
of secretary of energy uh jennifer
granholm she was in the little
compilation we just showed you there
talking about how we can't let this
ukrainian moment go to waste because
there's something else going on here
maybe it has something to do with a new
world order as you can imagine and as
you have heard there is a lot of
conversation that is happening right now
in in saying that this crisis
in uh in europe and the crisis our
allies are facing and the reduction of
supply of
natural gas and oil from russia
creates a moment that we should be
acting i mean we heard president
zielinski we do not want to see
any country that is held hostage to
vladimir putin
and this is a moment for congress to be
able to act
there can be a compromise there can be
movement on this
um and whether it's you know i mean what
the form is and
sponsors are and all of that that's uh
that's a conversation that's happening
but the bottom line is
this is a moment to have this happen
it's an urgent moment
what this is what a crazy coincidence
guys i actually can't believe this these
people who all want us to move off of
energy the way we've done it for so long
and we can again have that conversation
about how we can clean up some things
related to all of that and how you
actually transition without destroying
an economy
they suddenly got this war out of
nowhere that no one's exactly sure
what's going on there and it's the
perfect moment for them to usher in the
thing that they want to usher in these
guys they're the luckiest people on
earth jennifer granholm
and joe biden are lucky they're just so
lucky and gay pete and all of them
they're just so lucky that we got this
war so they could do their energy thing
it's just great okay so we're laying out
a case here what do we have we've got
police we've got ice we've got border
we've got inflation we've got oil and
gas no drilling so we can move to
electric but i would imagine that the
rest of our foreign policy has been
pretty solid right it's not like there
was any sort of disaster uh say eight
months ago or something something that
was so
unbelievably horrible that
it actually shook people to their very
foundations although we don't talk about
it anymore there could have been such a
thing like that maybe in august related
to afghanistan
kabul airport this morning is back up
and running evacuation flights for u.s
embassy personnel and contractors in
full swing
flights were stopped yesterday when tens
of thousands of afghans stormed onto the
runways desperate to leave clinging onto
aircraft trying not to be left behind as
the americans pull out
u.s troops found themselves overwhelmed
as they tried to clear the airport
firing warning shots the pentagon says
american troops killed two armed afghans
but some afghans were able to get out on
one flight so full it may have set a
record for the number of people who can
fit onto an american c-17
afghans are running from the taliban now
in full control setting up checkpoints
with the very weapons american taxpayers
bought for the afghan army which
collapsed instead of fighting after the
u.s pulled out of bases and left them
without air support
okay so we obviously could have shown
you far more horrific video out of
afghanistan doesn't that feel like a
lifetime ago when you watch that it's
like man remember that the 13 marines
who died there uh how we abandoned the
afghani translators and people that were
helping us work on the ground the the
billions
the billions of dollars worth of
equipment that has fallen into the hands
of the taliban we don't discuss any of
this stuff anymore and i was never for
the afghanistan war it was the longest
war in american history and we had to
figure out how to get out
but do you think if you wanted to harm
america's reputation across the world
and make our allies go man what are
these people doing and you wanted to
make people wonder about the
the true nature of what the united
states is um do you think perhaps you
would leave the exact way that we did
in that embarrassing disaster and of
course now chinese and russian influence
in afghanistan is growing we know that's
growing so could that have a little
something to do with ushering in a new
world order you sort of make us look
like fools on the national stage but
okay i'm talking about foreign policy
let's bring it back here to the united
states there was this thing you may
remember some of you may remember this
those of you who've really been paying
attention there was this thing called
kovid for a while this is where people
were wrapping their heads in cellophane
and staying in underground bunkers and
ordering in chinese takeout for a while
because you had to do that to make sure
grandma didn't die um well there was
this guy anthony fauci from the nih and
uh he's been a public servant for a
couple decades now uh unclear how much
he's done that's ever been good it's
very unclear actually and a lot of
people think he's done an awful lot of
bad um and he's lied to us many times
over and he could be in a lot of trouble
if the republicans take congress again
as uh my friend rand paul has already
pointed out they will try to drag him in
and actually break up the position and
and
he could face all sorts of punishment
but anyway here's anthony fauci a few
days after the 2020 election november
12th
to be precise so this is right after
biden won the election uh when fauci
decided to really tell us
who's in charge
so are there countries that you the
other countries that seem to be doing
well that then weren't doing so are
there countries now that hold up as
models for
you know pretty good response to this
you know the answer is yes but right now
it seems that every country is suffering
we are often compared with countries
that are not comparable to us we are not
a little island of five million people
that we can shut off
we're not a
country that would accept if a ruler
tells us you must do this i was talking
with our uk colleagues
just today
who were saying the uk is very similar
to where we are now in outbreak because
each of our countries have that
independent spirit but we don't want to
be told what to do
well i understand that but now is the
time to do
what you're told
and i think it really is something that
we should be doing right now
the laugh right it's the laugh after now
is the time to do what you're told like
man you just scratch one of these people
you scratch a government worker you
scratch a lefty progressive and the
worst sort of tyrannical authoritarian
just comes out and it's so interesting
because that which also feels like a
really long time ago but it's only a
year and a half ago right after the
election of 2020 um you can see the way
it shifted where he's actually talking
about freedom there are some things that
we can't do there's the streak of
independence uh
we are he says we are not a country who
would accept that you will do this
meaning that we'll accept mandates and
lockdowns and everything else and then
he pushed the hell out of mandates which
now are disappearing because good
american people fought back against it
but that was a year and a half ago uh
now that uh kovid seems to be wrapping
up although season two is coming i'm
pretty sure of that uh here's fauci a
couple days ago uh and he's uh he's
digging the the lockdowns and all the
other stuff and maybe they will make a
comeback if we do see
a significant surge particularly one
that might result in increased
hospitalizations we have to be prepared
to pivot and perhaps reinstitute some of
those restrictions
no anthony we are not reinstituting
those restrictions you are not the god
of us you are not an elected official
and i think there's an argument to be
made that even the elected officials
don't have the right to lock our
businesses and keep us in our homes and
enter everything else
um
and thankfully i live in the free state
of florida and i know that the governor
here will not listen to any of your
nonsense and we have a surgeon general
here latipo who's actually following the
science so i think we've laid out quite
a case here do you see what we did there
uh we talked about the police they tried
to destroy our policing which then
destroyed our cities and crime has
exploded we know that and all the videos
people walking into drug stores stealing
stuff you know what's going on in san
francisco and most of our major cities
and the amount of murders that are
rising and everything else we talked
about ice so they don't want illegal
people that are here to be dealt with
they just want illegal people to be here
and once you're here illegally then the
rest of your life is an illegal process
and we again we can talk about what do
you do about the 12 million people who
were born here and that are living good
lives and all of those things okay but
you see what we're doing here we they
don't want voter ids right when i voted
in the presidential election and for the
recall in california i tried to show my
id and they would not let me do it i
literally tried to do it so they want to
get rid of the police they want to get
rid of ice we showed you the video from
the border they're more than happy to
let all these people rush in and we
showed you the numbers they're actually
doing it uh we talked about inflation
inflation going up now 7.9 percent which
probably means that it's more and what
again that means is that you have
basically eight percent less money than
you think you have so when you're
looking at your account take it off
eight percent uh then we've got all the
gas situation uh which is completely
insane as you've seen uh i saw there was
one in i think it was in northern cali
uh diesel was 9.99 a gallon 9.99 a
gallon it's happening but as joe biden
said it has nothing to do with him
it has nothing to do with him and the
new world order thing also is a complete
conspiracy theory right we had a six
trillion dollar rescue plan we didn't
have six trillion dollars we borrowed
the six trillion dollars or we just
printed it
does that do anything to the economy
then of course we talked about the move
to electric cars that's obviously
connected to that they want to usher in
their new world electric grid situation
then foreign policy we
basically left afghanistan in shambles
said to all of our allies hey we don't
know what the hell we're doing and then
of course we brought it back home to the
people that have been running this
country related to kovid and they're
sitting there laughing saying we may
have to institute some of the stuff
again even though the stuff didn't work
we've got a close a cold clothes for you
today that i think you're going to dig
because if any of this is concerning to
you this was a guess i guess guys this
was a little bit of a concerning show
today this was a concerning show so
we're going to end you with hope because
there is a woman
by the name of kamala harris and she's
second in charge and she's good this is
a woman who knows her [ __ ] she's good
we've got video to prove it that we're
going to show you
in just a second this woman seriously
knows what she's doing and if anything
you know joe biden if one morning you
know fell down the stairs whatever it is
uh
she'd be in charge and everything would
be okay uh guys i want to remind you
before we show you that video trust me
you want to stick around for a moment uh
that the uh book tour for don't burn
this country is coming out uh you can
get tickets at daverubin.com
events and i've got great guests and i
just i really i promise you it's gonna
be a show like you've never seen before
i'll do a different show every single
night great guests like dennis prager
megan kelly megan mccain glenn beck
larry elder benny johnson michael malus
andrew clavin we're going to add a bunch
more i'm just waiting on a couple
schedules to fall out
i really really think you'll dig it you
get a book by the way with every ticket
ordered regular seat or vip the vip
seats are selling out super fast people
want the handshake they want the
handshake and the one second hug and i
will oblige
part one of my interview with judge
andrew napolitano is up right now we get
into a lot of the legal stuff that's
happening right now between what
happened with jesse smellette just
walking out of jail basically
and uh the supreme court nominee which
is the hearings are happening right now
we'll have more on that later in the
week and a whole bunch of other stuff
he's really interesting guy and on that
note people
i know it was a bit of a scary show it
was a bit alarmist you know i like to
give you guys hope and i think we do
have hope
we have hope
in two words
kamala
harris
the governor and i and we were all
doing a tour of the library here and on
talking about the significance of the
passage of time
right the significance of the passage of
time
so when you think about it there is
great significance to the passage of
time in terms of what we need to do to
lay these wires what we need to do to
create these jobs and there is such
great significance to the passage of
time when we think about a day
in the life of our children